[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم واهلا بكم في حصاد الليله
معكم محمد كريشان في هذه اللحظات عواصم
ومدن في العالم تعيش على وقع احداث هامه
البدايه من العاصمه الامريكيه واشنطن التي
تردنا منها هذه الصور في ظل توتر جديد في
العلاقات الامريكيه الصينيه بسبب توقيع
واشنطن على الجزء الاول مما يسمى مبادره
الولايات المتحده تايوان بشان التجاره في
القرن الحادي والعشرين
اما هذه الصور فتردنا من العاصمه الروسيه
موسكو بعد اتهام الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين من سماهم الاعداء بانهم يحولون
زعزعه الوضع داخل بلاده وان موسكو لن تسمح
بذلك
ومن ام درمان السودانيه بعد تعليق
المحادثات في جده بين طرفي الصراع ومخاوف
من صراع طويل الامد ومعاناه واسعه النطاق
مع فشل وقف اطلاق النار بين الطرفين
وفي مواضيع الحصاد بهذه الليله
في خضم مشهد توتر واتهامات تتزايد بجرائم
كراهيه ضد المسلمين في الهند برنامج
المسافه صفر يكشف بالوثائق والشهادات عن
وجود تنظيمات هندوسيه متطرفه تستهدف
المسلمين بعضها بتدريب من الجيش
وقوانين تهدد نحو 700 الف مسلم بولايه
اسام بالترحيل وسحب الجنسيه ومتحدث باسم
الحزب الحاكم ينفي اي ممارسات تمييز ويقول
ان الحكومه الهنديه ترفض الانف
وزير الدفاع الامريكي يصافح نظيره صيني في
منتدى شنغريلا والبنتاجون يقول ان الحفاظ
على خطوط اتصال بين جيشي البلدين يبقى
اولويه
ومستشار الامن القومي الامريكي يدعو الى
منع نشوب صراع نووي اصبح محتملا ويتهم
الصين بحسب معلومات عن توسع تورسانتها
ويدعوها وروسيا الى التفاوض دون شروط
مسبقه على الحد من التسلح
فيرود وزابولوجيا ضربات تتوسع على مناطق
داخل روسيا واخرى خاضعه لسيطرتها كيف
تتحدث عن اخلاء روسي عاجل لبناء برديانس
على بحر ازوف بعد انفجار ضخم
يدعو مجلس الامن الروسي للتصدي لخطط زعزعه
الوضع الداخلي
يامر بفحص شامل للهياكل الدفاعيه في
البلاد مع استمرار الضربات الروسيه
معارك معنيفه في غرب الخرطوم ومناطق اخرى
غداه تعليق محادثات جده ومصدر في الجيش
يقلل من تاثير العقوبات والقيود الامريكيه
ويؤكد للجزيره شده تداعياتها على الدعم
السريع وقوات الدعم تقول ان العقوبات غير
مجديه في حل النزاعات والامم المتحده تقول
ان مرافق انسانيه ومستودعات امميه تتعرض
للنهب في السودان
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصائد على منصاتنا
الرقميه كنا ناقشنا معكم الاوضاع المترقبه
بعد تعليق واشنطن والرياض مباحثات جدا بين
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريعه وقد
فرضت واشنطن كما هو معلوم عقوبات وقيودا
على التاشيرات ضد طرفي النساء لاستطلاع
ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا
عليكم السؤال التالي والذي يقول الى اين
تتجه الامور بعد تعليق محادثات جده بشان
السودان 50% قالوا ان القتال سيستمر دون
حسم
اربعون بالمئه راوا ان احد الطرفين سيحسم
الامر ميدانيا بينما راى عشره بالمئه
مرشحين الجلوس من جديد بين الطرفين
للتفاوض
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا كالعاده على
منصاتنا الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه
التصويت عبر مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر حاليا
على الشاشه
لقاؤنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوليا
وتتابعون معنا في حصاد هذه الليله
احتجاجات مستمره وتوتر متصاعد في شمال
كوسوفو رئيس الوزراء يتهم صربيا بتدبير
الاشتباكات بين الصرب وقوه السلام التابعه
للنيتو والممثل الخاص للاتحاد الاوروبي
للحوار بين صربيا وكوسوفو ينتقد
الانتخابات البلديه ويبدا في تصريح
للجزيره الى ضروره اعادتها
[موسيقى]
كشف برنامج المسافه صفر في تحقيقه
الميداني الجديد تحت عنوان الهند من اشعل
الفتيل تحدث عن وجود حملات في عده ولايات
هنديه لهدم ممتلكات المسلمين من منازل
وشركات وكيف ان منظمه هندوسيه متطرفه تقف
وراء ارتفاع جرائم الكراهيه في جميع انحاء
البلاد وقد تمكن فريق البرنامج من الحصول
على شهادات لضحايا مسلمين تم احتجازهم في
معسكرات اعتقال بحجه انهم مهاجرون غير
شرعيين وذلك ضمن خطه
لتهدد نحو 700 الف هندي مسلم في ولايه
باسقاط الجنسيه والترحيل وفقا لتعديل جديد
على قانون المواطنه المقر من قبل البرلمان
الهندي
الهند من اشعل الفتيل بهذا العنوان عاد
البرنامج الاستقصائي المسافه صفر بموسمه
الجديد فاتحا ملف مسلمي الهند الذين
يعيشون منذ سنوات اضطهادا وهجمات متصاعده
من قبل جماعات هندوسيه متطرفه
لمقابله الضحايا ورصد المشهد من المسافه
الصفراء سعى فريق البرنامج للوصول الى
الولايات الهنديه من اقصى الشمال الشرقي
الى اقصى الجنوب الغربي والتي تعيش عنفا
وتمييزا ممنهجا ضد المسلمين
كشفت تحقيق بالوثائق والشهاده عن وجود
تنظيمات متطرفه سعت على مدار سنوات
لاستهداف المسلمين
فقد حصل برنامج المسافه صفر على شهاده
نادره لعضو المنشق عن منظمه الاتحاد
الوطني الهندسي ار اس اس المتطرفه تكشف
الشهاده عن مخططات لنشر العنف ضد المسلمين
في البلاد مع وجود نيه واضحه للتسبب في
خسائر فاتحه في ارواح المسلمين
المتحدث باسم الحزب الحاكم نفى هذه
الاتهامات وكذب شهاده المنشق عن سيد هذا
الرجل غير ملتزم وهذا ليس ما نتماهى معه
وانا واثق جدا انه يكذب
لكن تحقيقا الفيدراليا اجرته الشرطه
الهنديه وحصل فريق المسافه صفر على نسخه
منه عزز من شهاده المنشق عن منظمه ار اس
استكشف نتائج تحقيق الفيدرالي بشكل واضح
عن وجود معسكرات تدريب سريه ومنشات لصنع
القنابل تتبع لسيطره المنظمه
باتت مقاطع الفيديو التي توافق اعتداء
المتطرفين الهندوس على المسلمين ومساجدهم
وممتلكاتهم حدثا يوميا في الهند يرى
مراقبون ان السلطات الهنديه لا تظهر جديه
في ربعه ولا يحظى باهتمام من قبل العالم
الاسلامي
تمكن فريق المسافه صفر ايضا من الوصول الى
ولايه اسام اقصى شمال شرقي البلاد والى
مدى براديش في الجنوب الغربي حيث يعيش
المسلمون في كلا الولايتين اضطهادا واسعا
وهجمات متصاعده من قبل المتطرفين الهندوس
اضيف اليها اجراءات حكوميه عقابيه
ففي ولايه اسام وحدها اقامت السلطات سبعه
مراكز احتجاز يقبع فيها عدد غير معروف من
المسلمين
فقط من يعتقلون
براديش تهدم الجرافات ممتلكات المسلمين
دون هواده
وضعت لطخ الجدران بلوث البقر اولا وقفت
امام البوابه اطلب منهم عدم هدم المنزل
سالتهم اين اذهب
بين الشرق والغرب تعددت الوجوه اختلفت
التفاصيل لكن الحكايه واحده
باتوا بين ليله وضحاها مهاجرين غير شرعيين
وما يزيد من قهرهم فقرهم وعدم قدرتهم على
دفع مستحقات محاميهم فمن يسمع انينهم ومن
يوقف الانتهاكات العلنيه بحقهم
ومعنى من لندن السيده فيكتوريا المؤرخه
والخبيره في الشؤون الاسيويه ومؤلفه كتاب
كشمير في الصراع الهند وباكستان والحرب
التي لا تنتهي اهلا بك سيدي
لماذا برايك لا تظهر السلطات الهنديه جديه
كبيره في وقف موجه الكراهيه هذه
والتنكيل بالمسلمين في الهند
انه امر مزعج جدا ان الحكومه لا تتخذ
موقفا جيدا لحمايه المسلمين بل عكس ذلك في
الواقع اذ ان ذلك يحصل هناك كانه راي بان
المسلمين هم الذين سوف يهجمون على
الهندوس وهناك حاله انكار شديده من
الحكومه حول كل ما يحصل ما تفسيرك للهند
التي يفترض ان يتعايش فيها الجميع
بنوع من التسامح تصل الى هذا المستوى من
التعامل
اعتقد ان ما شاهدناه في السنوات 75
الماضيه منذ استقلال الهند هو ان الامر
بدا والفكر الاوليه كانت ان الهند ستكون
دوله علمانيه
وذلك استقلت عنها تكون دوله المسلمين لكن
نقلهم ذلك بقي اعداد كبيره من المسلمين في
الهند وهم يشكلون مشكله جزء كبير من
المجتمع الهندي اذا كان اضافه الى عدد
كبير من الطوائف والاديان الاخرى ما
شاهدنا في السنوات ال 25 الماضي خاصه منذ
الوصول حكومه بي جي بي الى السلطه ان هناك
تغيير في الروايه وهي ان الهند ليست دوله
علمانيه بل هي الدوله للهندوس وهي دوله
هندوسيه وهذا ما ادى الى هذه الهجمات
المباشره على المسلمين وعلى اصحاب
الديانات الاخرى فما يحصل هو روايه وقول
على مستوى الشارع لا غير مفهومه وبالتالي
فياخذ الناس تطبيق القانون بايديهم كما
شاهدنا في عرسان وفي مناطق اخرى في الواقع
في الهند هل ترين السيده ان هناك نوع ايضا
من التقصير العالمي في تسليط الضوء على
معاناه المسلمين هناك
هناك عدد كثير من
مدافعين حقوق الانسان يطرحون هذا الموضوع
ويثبتون الانتباه الجمهور اليه ولكن
المشكله كما نعلم هناك الكثير من المشاكل
التي تجعل الاذهان القاده في العالم
وقد يكون من الممكن انه ليس هناك ما يكفي
من انتباه يعلق على ما يحصل في الهند لان
الهند هي تقنيا تعتبر حنيفه الولايات
المتحده والمملكه المتحده والدول الاخرى
وعندما نضع ذلك للسياقه الاقليميه فيها
حول ما يحصل في الصين
وفي روسيا بحيث ان هذا الاحتجاز ليس كبيرا
كما ينبغي وان الارجح ان ان الفهم لانه
ليس من الصحب ليس من
سهل السفر في هذه المناطق وفهم بالضبط ما
الذي يحصل في ذلك البلد غير موجود ولا يع
لن عنه بشكل كافي وهل ترين كذلك ان حتى
العالم الاسلامي مقصر في متابعه هذه
المساله
نعم نعم نفس الشيء ينطبق عليهم
فالدول الاخرى كمان نعلم لديها اولوياتها
الخاصه بها ومخاوفها الخاصه ولكن من الوضع
انا اقول مدافع حقوق الانسان بانه اينما
يكون هناك حقوق الانسان
لابد من ارتفاع الاصوات الاحتجاج على ذلك
شكرا جزيلا لك سيده فيكتوريا من لندن
[موسيقى]
في خطوه لافته شهدها منتدى شانجريلا للامن
والدفاع الاسيوي في سنغافوره صفح وزير
الدفاع الامريكي نظيره الصيني
لكن المتحدث باسم الفانتاغون قله قال ان
المصافحه جرت دون تبادل اي حديث جوهري
واضاف المتحدث ان واشنطن تؤكد ضروره
الحفاظ على خطوط اتصال مفتوحه بين الجيشين
الصيني والامريكي وتشهد العلاقات بين
البلدين توتنا متناميا في عده ملفات
ابرزها التقارب الامريكي مع تايوان
مصافحه ليس اكثر لا صفحه ولا تقارب ولا
اجتماع هذا ما حدث بعد ايام من رفض بيجين
طلب واشنطن عقد لقاء بين وزيري الدفاع
البلدين
على هامش قمه شانجريلا حضر الوزيران الى
سنغافوره للمشاركه في اعمال قمه امنيه
اسيويه ما يجري في كواليسها من مناورات
دبلوماسيه اهم بكثير من الكلام الذي يقال
من منبر المداخلات الوزير الصيني الذي
صفحه اوستن يخضع لعقوبه امريكيه منذ 2018
بسبب صفقه اسلحه مع روسيا سرع البنتاجون
الى وضعنا جرى في سنغافوره في الاطار الذي
يراه قال انه واشنطن تؤكد ضروره الحفاظ
على خطوط اتصال مفتوحه بين الجيشين الصيني
والامريكي مضيفا ان السعي متواصل لاجراء
محادثات هادفه على مستوى القيادتين
العسكريتين للبل
بين القول والفعل تبدو الامور اكثر تعقيدا
اي تقرب من سلطات يزيد من تباعد فرص خفض
التوتر بين واشنطن
والاتفاق التجاري الذي حمل اسم مبادره
الولايات المتحده وتايوان للتجاره في
القرن الحادي والعشرين بالنظر الصين
استفزاز اخر غير مقبول وصفته تايوان
بالاتفاق التاريخي والبدايه الجديده
واعربت الخارجيه الصينيه عن غضبها ورفضها
لتلك الخطوه التي تتعارض مع مبدئي صيني
واحده
الصين غير راضيه بشده على هذا الانتهاك
الخطير لوعود الولايات المتحده بالحفاظ
على علاقات غير رسميه مع تايوان وقدمنا
احتجاجات صارمه للولايات المتحده
يصعب تحديد نبره تصريحات الرئيس جو بايدن
الاخيره هي مهادنه متحديه ام الاثنتان معا
قال ان واشنطن لا تسعى الى صراع مع بيجين
ولكنها ستقف الى جانب اصدقائها وستواصل
التنافس مع الصين حدود التنافس وسقفه
مفتوحه جغرافيا وسياسيا وعسكريا ايضا جهد
واشنطن لضم اكبر عدد من العواصم الاسيويه
الى جبهتها المعاديه للصين تشهد وتيره
اكبر منذ حرب روسيا في اوكرانيا هذا ما
يظهر للعلن ولكن في السر لم تنقطع
الاتصالات بين واشنطن بغض النظر عن
المبادر والدافع سبق انكشفت تقارير
الصحفيه عن زياره غير معلنه لمدير وكاله
الاستخبارات المركزيه الامريكيه ويليامبرز
الى الصين في مايو الماضي امتنع البيت
الابيض والسي اي اي عن التعليق ان مسؤولا
امريكيا
قال ان التقى خلال الزياره بمسؤولين في
المخابرات الصينيه ليس كل ما يجري بين
واشنطن وبيدين يرى ويسمع تكتيكات صراع
النفوذ بين القوتين لا تمنع حدوث مصافحه
حتى لو غابت الثقه بينهما
مستشار الامن القوميه الامريكيه جيكس
سوليفان ان بلادها بلاده في نقطه تحول
بشان الامن النووي وتحتاج الى ما وصفه
باستراتيجيات تحول دون نشوب صراع النووي
وفي كلمه القاها خلال الاجتماع السنوي
لجمعيه الحد من التسلح في واشنطن اضاف
سلمان ان النهج الذي تتبناه بلاده في تلك
الاستراتيجيه ياخذ في الاعتبار تقنيات
جديده يمكن ان تعقد نزاعا نوويا محتملا
وفق تعبيره
النهج الذين تبناه ياخذ في الاعتبار
تقنيات وادوات يمكن ان تشعل نزاعا نوويا
محتملا مثل الاسلحه الفرد صوتيه والانظمه
التي تعمل بتقنيه الذكاء الاصطناعي وكما
قال الرئيس بايدن اننا نحرص على التاكد من
اننا لا نقود بنموذج قوتنا فحسب وانما
بقوه نموذجنا ايضا وهذا هو سبب التزامنا
بعدم اجراء اختبار صاروخي مدمر للاقمار
الاصطناعيه ونشجع حلفائنا وشركائنا
ومنافسين على الالتزام بذلك ايضا
اضاف كذلك ان الصين اختارت عدم الجلوس الى
طاوله المفاوضات لاجراء حوار موضوعي حول
الحد من التسلح ورفضت المشاركه بشان حجم
قوتها النوويه ونطاقها وفق تعبيرها
النوويه او تقديم اختاراتهم بشان
الاختبارات كما انها لم تظهر اهتماما
كبيرا بالمناقشات المتعلقه بالتغييرات
التي تجريها على قوتها النوويه
وببساطه لم نشهد بعد اظهار الصين رغبه
لفصل الاستقرار الاستراتيجي عن القضايا
الاوسع في العلاقه والفصل بين القضيتين
كان على مدى عقود حجر اساس للامن النووي
والاستقرار الاستراتيجي
وبشان روسيا انتقد مستشار الامن القومي
الامريكي تعليق الرئيس فلاديمير بوتين
العمل بمعاهده ستارت الجديده مشيرا الى
استعداد بلاده الدخول في مباحثات مع موسكو
لاداره المخاطر النوويه والحد من الاسلحه
لما بعد عام 2026 كذلك دعا سلمان كلا من
موسكو وبيجين الى التفاوض دون شروط مسبقه
على الحد من التسلح
ليس من مصلحه بلدينا الشروع في منافسه
مفتوحه في القوه النوويه الاستراتيجيه
ونحن على استعداد للالتزام بالحدود الوسطى
طالما التزمت بذلك روسيا وبدلا من انتظار
ايجاد حل لجميع خلافاتنا الثنائيه فان
واشنطن مستعده الان للدخول في مباحثات مع
روسيا لاداره المخاطر النوويه وتطوير اطار
عمل للحد من الاسلحه لما بعد عام 2026
هذه التصريحات والمواقف تفتح الباب على
مساحات التنافس العسكريه الامريكي مع
الصين وروسيا لاسيما فيما يتعلق بالاسلحه
النوويه الاستراتيجيه
كان العالم اكثر هدوءا عام 2010 حينها وقع
الرئيسان الامريكي والروسي اتفاقيه نيو
ستارت تلك اتفاقيه تمنع الطرفين من زياده
قدراتهم النوويه تمتلك روسيا والولايات
المتحده معا حوالي 90% من الرؤوس النوويه
في العالم رقم يدفع الطرفين للتاكيد على
ضروره تجنب اندلاع حرب بين القوتين
النوويتين باي ثمن بعد تولي بايدن الاداره
الامريكيه تم تمديد اتفاقيه نيو ستارت عام
2021 لخمس سنوات بموجب الاتفاق يلتزم
البلدان بنشر ما لا يزيد على 1550 راسا
نوويا استراتيجيا وسبعمائه من الصواريخ
بعيده المدى وقاذفات القنابل بحد اقصى
تتعامل معاهده نيو ستارت كذلك مع الصواريخ
النوويه طويله المدى وعابره القارات
بعد عام من اندلاع حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
اعلنت روسيا انسحابها من معاهده نيو ستارت
السبب هو ان الولايات المتحده تستخدم
معاهده لمساعده اوكرانيا في مهاجمه
المواقع الاستراتيجيه الروسيه هكذا قالت
روسيا في تبرير قرار الانسحاب حذرت
الولايات المتحده من تداعيات الانسحاب
الروسي وقالت انه تم بشكل غير قانوني يعود
التحذير الامريكي مره اخرى اليوم لكنه لا
يتوقف عندما تقوم به روسيا تظهر واشنطن
خشيتها من الصين يقول مستشار الامن القومي
الامريكي ان بيجي تسعى الامتلاك ما يصل
الى 1500 راس حربي نووي بحلول عام 2035
هذا رقم يوازي ما تمتلكه روسيا والولايات
المتحده مجتمعتين مما يزيد الخشيه
الامريكيه رفض الصين مشاركه المعلومات
بشان حجمي ونطاق قواتها النوويه ولا تقدم
اي اخطارات لما تقوم به هذا ما يقوله
مسؤولون في البيت الابيض الاع الامريكيه
على ما يزيد احتمالات نشوب نزاع نووي على
راس القائمه لذلك الاسلحه الفرط صوتيه
والانظمه العامله بالذكاء الاصطناعي تمت
مساحات عسكريه اخرى للتنافس الامريكي
الصيني لا تتوقف عند محاولات الصين بناء
قواعد عسكريه في افريقيا وتعزيز قدراتها
النوويه ولا محاولات الولايات المتحده
تقديم دعم لتايوان التي تعتبرها الصين
جزءا من اراضيها اما التنافس الامريكي مع
روسيا فزاد من اشتعاله حرب اوكرانيا
المستمره ولا يبدو انه تنافس ستخفق
نيرانهم في المدى المنظور لا على خط
العلاقه الامريكيه الصينيه ولا على الخط
الامريكي الروسي
معنى من واشنطن مارك لاعب مساعد وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه السابق لشؤون نزع
الاسلحه النوويه
نائب رئيس جمعيه الدبلوماسيين الروس اهلا
بضيفينا نبدا من واشنطن السيد فيس باتريك
كيف ستتعامل واشنطن مع هذا الاستعصاء في
الملف الاسلحه
الاستراتيجيه والنوويه مع روسيا ومع الصين
في نفس الوقت
شكرا لاستضافه ان هذا موقف وضع صعب جدا في
هذا الصباح كنت في فعاليه كان فيها
مستشار الامن القومي
يتحدث عن هذه الصعوبه وقد وضح بين
الولايات المتحده مستعده للتواصل مع كل من
روسيا والصين حول السيطره على الصلاح بدون
اي شروط مستعدون للحديث معهم حول ذلك
والشرط وكلمه غير مشروط هذا كلام لم نسمعه
سابقا وبالتالي الولايات المتحده تريد
فعلا ان تتواصل معهما لتقليل المخاطر
النوويه ولكن الامر يتطلب طرفين الاتفاق
على اي شيء
وان اي الموسكا ولا بيجين يبدو انهما في
مزاج حاليا للتواصل حول التواصل مع
مناقشات تسيطر على السلاح النووي ولكن
الا تعتقد بان واشنطن عقدت علاقاتها مع
واشنط مع مع موسكو وبيجين الى درجه لم يعد
فيها سهلا الخوض في هذا النقاش
انا افهم متى النقطه سؤالك هذا ولكن
نستطيع ان نرى من ناحيه التاريخيه ان
الولايات المتحده
وروسيا استطاعا التواصل حول السيطره على
السلع حتى في اوقات صعبه جدا اثناء الحرب
البارده
استطاع انذاك ان يقسموا ويوزعوا مسائل
السيطره على السلاح الى اجزاء والبعير
يقلل المخاطر النوويه حتى اثناء كونهما في
اوضاع او علاقات صعبه جدا مع اتحاد
السوفيتي انذاك اما اليوم لا يبدو مهتما
بتوزيع المساله القضايا
النوويه بل التعامل معها كلها بشكل شامل
وكما قلت انت فهم لا يريدون الفصل موضوع
القضايا النوويه عن صعوباتنا ومشاكلنا مع
روسيا حول اوكرانيا ومع الصين لدينا مشاكل
خلافات كبيره هل معنى ذلك يا سيد
في موسكو ان الكرملين يريد ان يجعل كل
القضايا في سله واحده لا تفاهمات في
الملفات النوويه او غيرها طالما لم نسوي
خلافاتنا السياسيه الاخرى في ملفات متعدده
ايه
اتفاق مع الولايات المتحده قد ضاعت لاننا
قمنا بوضع الترتيبات المهمه جدا وخطيره
ولكن قبل 20 22 سنه
واشنطن بدات بنزعه او تفكيك هذا الاتفاق
وفي الواقع
نحن لدينا شكوك بان موسكو تكون جاده
ونشكر
بجديتها في اي ترتيبات مستقبليه لذلك نحن
نهمل هذه الفرصه الممنوحه ولا نعتمد الا
على توازن القوى طبعا المترجم يقصد واشنطن
في موضوع الثقه وليس وليس موسكو طبعا في
هذه الحاله سيد بك لانوف
لماذا الاتحاد السوفياتي السابق وحتى
روسيا
نجحت في الفصل بين القضايا الاستراتيجيه
الكبرى والملفات العالقه بين البلدين
لماذا الان تريد الدمجه بينهما
الوضع تغير تماما
الان
لا يتعلق او ليس الصله بالوضع اللي كان
السائدا في السبعينيات والثمانينيات اولا
هناك الحرب في اوكرانيا
في الواقع ان هذه حرب بين روسيا والنيتو
ككتله
وفي النيتو وفي اوروبا لديها غالبيه تفوق
اربعه الى واحد فيما يتعلق بالاسلحه
التقليديه وبالتالي فان وزير الدفاع عن
روسيا
اوضح بشكل لا لبس فيه بانه لو شعرنا بخطر
حقيقي على انفسنا فاننا لن نتردد باستخدام
الاسلحه النوويه في اوروبا ولكن المشكله
الوحيده هو ان الموقف الولايات المتحده
مرتاحه جدا فهي طرق ما يجري في اوروبا
التي بعيده جدا عن اي استخدام لاستخدام
سلاح نووي والكثير من الناس واتصين فيه في
روسيا يرون
ان هذا وضع خطير
وعلينا
ان نبعث باشارات واضحه جدا الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه بانه لو كان هناك بدء
للحرب نوويه في اوروبا فان سيكون هناك رد
وهجمات
الرد على ذلك مباشره من روسيا على امريكا
وربما في المرحله الاولى
ربما لو استمر ربما لو استمر بعد اذنك لو
استمر الموقف الروسي بهذا الشكل نسال سيد
بيتس باتريك في واشنطن لو استمرت واشنطن
في هذا الموقف المتصلب هل يمكن ان تتنازل
واشنطن في الملفات العالقه بين البلدين
لتسهيل المسائل الاستراتيجيه والنوويه
اعتقد ان واشنطن
لطالما اظهرت رغبتها وارادتها بان تكون
مرنه واعتقد هناك نقطتان لابد ان نركز
عليهما اولهما وانا احترم ضيفكم في موسكو
ومقاله ولكن الامر لا يتعلق بحرب بين
روسيا والنيتو هذه حرب حرب عدوانيه
قامت بها روسيا ضد اوكرانيا والنيوت فقط
يقدمون المساعده لاوكرانيا فقط بالسلاح
وليس بالقوات وبالتالي في الولايات
المتحده وشركائها في النيتو حريصون جدا
بان لا
يشاركوا بانفسهم في هذه الحرب ليس اي قوات
تحارب روسيا في هذه الحرب ولكن النقطه
الثانيه لو ان روسيا استخدمت السلاح
النووي في الحرب الاوكرانيه فانه الولايات
المتحده وشغلها في النيتو يردون بطرق
واساليب ستكون كارثيه جدا لروسيا ولكن ليس
بالضروره باستخدام سلاح النووي الولايات
المتحده وشرقائها في النيتو لديهم الكثير
من الاسلحه التقليديه المتفوقه التي يمكن
تدمر الجيش الروسي ويمكن يستخدموها اذا
استخدمت روسيا السلاح النووي لكن الولايات
المتحده لا اريد تصعيد الامور لتصل الى
حرب النوويه شكرا لضيفينا سيد ماركس
باتريك من واشنطن وسيد اندري بلكانوف من
موسكو
[موسيقى]
هذا ايفاننا عمده مدينه
الاوكرانيه في مقاطعه ان القوات الروسيه
بدات بمغادره ميناء مدينه التي تسيطر
عليها في المقاطعه الجنوبيه بعد وقوع
انفجار ضخم واضاف ان مغادره الميناء تتم
بشكل عاجل حيث تعمل القوات على ازاله
المعدات وتحويل مسار السفن التي كانت
تستخدمها في تصدير الحبوب الاوكرانيه
المسروقه وفق تعبيرها وفي الداخل الروسي
اعلن حاكم مقاطعه
الروسيه مقتله شخصين واصابه اخرين في قصف
اوكراني استهدف مناطق سكنيه عده في
المقاطعه ونشر موقع
التابعه لوزاره الدفاع الروسيه صورا تظهر
تصاعدا اعمده الدخان من مباني سكنيه في
مدينه شبيكيونو بمقاطعه الروسيه واعلن
حاكم المقاطعه ان انقطاع التيار الكهربائي
والمياه بشكل كامل عن هذه المدينه
قد اتهم الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
خلال تراسه اجتماعا دوريا لمجلس الامن
الروسي من سماهم الاعداء بانهم يحاولون
زعزعه الوضع داخل بلاده قائلا ان موسكو لن
تسمح لهم بذلك
كما تعلمون في الاونه الاخيره تناولت
وزملائي قضايا العلاقات بين القوميات في
البلاد بالنسبه لروسيا هذه القضايا في
غايه الاهميه مع الاخذ في الاعتبار ان
لدينا 190 قوميه تعيش في البلاد وعليه
سنتناول اليوم هذه القضايا في اطار مساله
ضمان امن روسيا اي الامن السياسي الداخلي
مع الاخذ في الاعتبار للجهود التي لا يزال
يبذلها خصومنا ويكثفونها من اجل اثاره
الوضع داخل روسيا يجب ان نفعل سويه ما
بوسعنا كي لا نسمح لهم تحت اي ظرف من
الظروف بفعل ذلك
وغداه ليله تخللها قصف واسع بالمسيرات
والصواريخ قال الرئيس الاوكراني
انه اصدر تعليمات بفحص شامل للهياكل
الدفاعيه في كييف ونظام الدفاع الجوي بهدف
صد التهديدات من البر والبحر والجو واضاف
زلل كانه امر باجراء تقرير استخباراتي
شامل عن الدول التي تساعد روسيا في زياده
انتاج الصواريخ والطائرات المسيره
معنا الان من عمان اللواء فايز الدويري
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي اهلا وسهلا
بك عندما يتحدث عن ضروره فحص شامل للهياكل
الدفاعيه فياب ما الذي يعنيه ذلك عمليا
يعني في الواقع هذه الحاله تنطبق على
جانبي الصراع الرئيس
الاوكراني تحدث صراحه واعاده تقييم
والرئيس الروسي تحدث عن محاوله احداث فتنه
داخليه وتحدث عن القوميات وبالتالي لا اجد
انسجاما وتطابقا ما بين تصريحات او
البيانات العسكريه وما بين تصريحات
السياسيين تصريحات السياسيين يمكن ان تفسر
على ان هناك فشل ولو جزئي في مضروبات
الدفاع الجوي في الجانب الاوكراني وفي
منظومات الدفاع الجوي والقوات حرس الحدود
الروسيه اذا اخذنا وتبنينا البيانات
العسكريه نجد ان نسبه النجاح في بعض
الحالات ترقى الى ميه بالميه 12 صاروخ تم
اسكندر تم اسقاطها 53 طائره مسيره تم
اسقاطها اذا لو كان هذا هذه البيانات
دقيقه
ويمكن البناء عليها لما تحدث الرئيس
الاوكراني عن ضروره اعاده تقييم الاداء
الفعلي لمنظومات الدفاع الجوي يقابل ذلك
ان البيانات التي تتعلق بالجانب الاخر
عندما تكون هناك هجوما داخل
او عندما تكون هناك هجمه صاروخيه على كيف
اذا ذهبنا باتجاه تصريحات الروسيه في حال
مهاجمه كيف الحديث عن اصابه بعض المنشات
العسكريه مبنى الاستخبارات اعطاب خمسه
طائرات النجاح في كذا يقابل ذلك الجانب
الاوكراني عندما نتحدث عن عمليه بريه
يتحدث عن انجازات ميدانيه كبيره تنكرها
روسيا اذا هناك حلقه مفقوده الحلقه
المفقوده تم توضيحها وتحديدها من خلال
تصريحات الزعامات ان هناك اخفاقات ميدانيه
لدى الجانبين والان كل جانب يسعى الى
تصويب مكامل الخطا وتصويب المسار
العملياتي لتقليل الخسائر والاضرار التي
تلحق من خلال القصف الذي يقوم به الجانب
الاخر كان لافتا ايضا فايز الدويري حديث
جالينسكي عن ضروره اجراء تحقيق استخبارات
شامل كما وصفه بالدول التي تساعد روسيا
سواء في الصواريخ او الطائرات المسيره
يعني الا يدري الى حد الان من يساعد روسيا
الحديث منذ بدايه استخدام الطائرات
المسيره والحديث عن جلب ذخائر مدفعيه من
كوريا الشماليه والحديث في وان كان تحت
الطاوله عن امكانيه تزويد ايران لروسيا
بصواريخ نحن كمحللين ومتابعين لدينا قطع
من المعلومات فيفترض بالجانب الروسي
الجانب الاوكراني ان يكون لديه صوره اوضح
ولكن اعتقد انه يريد ان يثبت ذلك بيع من
خلال
وثائق تدين بصوره فاضحه في لانه على سبيل
المثال ايران قالت نعم زودنا النظام
الروسي بطائرات شاهد 136 قبل الحرب
ولم تكن هناك حرب الان هو يطالب بتقديم
بيانات تفصيليه في اعداد الطائرات واوقات
تسليمها فبالتالي يكون لديه الحجه لمواجهه
ايران او مواجهه اي دوله اخرى تدعم روسيا
كما ان روسيا تعمل بهذا الاتجاه من اجل
التحقق ماذا قدمت المانيا ماذا قدمت
بريطانيا الاعداد الانواع والتواريخ شكرا
جزيلا لك لواء فايز الدويري من عمان
[موسيقى]
جمع محتجون صرب في محيط مقر لثلاثه بلديات
شمالي كوسوفو لليوم السادس مطالبين بسحب
قوات الشرطه من المكان وعدم دخول رؤساء
البلديات المنتخبين اخيرا من جهتي اتهم
رئيس الوزراء كوسوفو البن كورتي اتهم
صربيا بتدبير الاشتباكات بين الصرب وقوه
حفظ السلامه التابعه للنيتو وفي تصريحات
للجزيره قال الممثل الخاص للاتحاد
الاوروبي للحوار بين بلغراد وبرشتينا
وقضايا غرب البلقان بيروت قال انه يجب
اعاده الانتخابات البلديه في شمال كوسوفو
لحل الوضع المتازم بين السلطات والصرف
احتياجات الاقليه الصربيه في شمال كوسوفو
مستمره طالب المحتجون الذين تجمعوا في
محيط مقر بلديه
بسحب قوات الشرطه وعدم دخول رؤساء
البلديات المنتخبين اخيرا قالوا انهم
مسالمون ويريدون الحريه ويصفون رؤساء
البلديات اولئك بانهم مزيفون وتواجه
السلطات الكوسوفو ضغوطا لتنظيم انتخابات
جديده في تلك البلديات بمشاركه الصرب وفي
تصريحات خاصه للجزيره جدد الممثل الخاص
للاتحاد الاوروبي للحوار بين بيل جراد
وبريتشنا ميروسلاف لاجاك تلك الدعوه
واعتبر ان فيها حل الوضع المتازم وان
تطبيع العلاقات
لا يمكن ان يتم دون ذلك
نعرف ان الصرب في كوسوف قطع الانتخابات
الماضيه وهم يمثلون اكثر من 90% في تلك
المناطق فهي من الناحيه القانونيه السليمه
لكنها من الناحيه السياسيه تفتقر الى
الشرعيه لذا يجب ان تكون هناك انتخابات
جديده بمشاركه صرب كوسوفو وسيساهم ذلك في
حل الوضع وخفض التوتر الحاصل الان
لكن قاده الكوسوفو يعتبرون ان التهديد
الحقيقي ياتي من صربيا التي يقولون انها
تنكر في الاصل وجود دوله كوسوفو وحمل رئيس
الوزراء البين كورتي بيل جراد مسؤوليه
الاضطرابات الراهنه ودعا خلال حديث
للبرلمان قائمه الصرب كوسوفو لتحمل نتائج
قرارهم بمقاطعه الانتخابات الاخيره
من هم في السلطه في بلغراد هم الذين
ينظمون هذه الاحتجاجات ما يعني انها ليست
احتجاجات حقيقيه انها لا تعكس اراده الشعب
الخطا الاساسي لقائمه حزب صربكوسوفو هو
مقاطعتها للانتخابات ولا ينبغي ان تدفع
ثمنه جمهوريتنا انه قرارهم السياسي ويجب
عليهم مواجهه العواقب غالبيه سكان كوسوفو
البالغ عددهم نحو مليوني شخص من الالبان
المسلمين بينما يقطن نحو 120 الف من الصرب
الارثوذكس في الشمال على حدود صربيا تتركز
الاضطرابات الحاليه في ثلاث بلديات شماليه
هي ليبو
سافيتشان وزوفين
جرت في هذه البلديات انتخابات في ابريل
الماضي نظمتها حكومه كوسوفو وشارك فيها
الف وخمسمائه ناخب فقط من اجمالي 45 الفا
مسجلين بعدما قاطعها جميع الصرب
ويذكر التوتر المتصاعد ولو من بعيد بالحرب
التي شهدتها كوسوفو عامي 98
وتسعه وتسعين من القرن الماضي والتي اودت
بحياه اكثر من عشره الاف شخص وشردت اكثر
من مليون اخرين
في ملف كوسوفو سيكون لنا بعد قليل حديث
معمق وموسى حول خلفيات التوتر الذي رافق
اقليم كوسوفو منذ ظهوره ككيان سياسي
[موسيقى]
في السودان تتواصل المعارك بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع فقد افاد مراسلون
بوقوع مواجهات في المنطقه الصناعيه ومنطقه
الامام غربي مدينه الخرطوم كما شهدت مناطق
جنوب ام درمان اشتباكات وسمع دوي انفجار
هناك وفي ولايه شمال كردفان افادت مصادر
محليه بتبادل اطلاق نار في مدينه الاوبيض
واعلنت المفوضيه الساميه للامم المتحده
لشؤون اللاجئين ان مستودعاتها في المدينه
استهدفت مما اعاق جهود الحفاظ على الدعم
للمحتاجين ودعت الوكاله لوقف مثل هذه
الهجمات
هذا وقد قال مارتن وكيلو الامين العام
للامم المتحده للشؤون الانسانيه ان الاصول
والمرافق الانسانيه في السودان تتعرض
للنهب على الرغم من تعهد الاطراف بخلاف
ذلك وذكر ان من بينها مستودعات تابعه
لبرنامج الاغذيه العالميه ومفوضيه شؤون
اللاجئين التي تعرضت للنهب في مدينه
الابيض وكذلك في الخرطوم
وغدا فرد العقوبات الامريكيه على السودان
قال مصدر مطلع في الجيش السوداني للجزيره
ان العقوبات الامريكيه لا تؤثر كثيرا فيما
قال يوسف عزه المستشار السياسي للقوات
الدعم السريع للجزيره ان العقوبات
الاقتصاديه غير مجديه في تسويه النزاعات
وقد جربت كما قال مع النظام المعزول ولم
تؤثر فيه وكانت الاداره الامريكيه فرضت
امس الخميس عقوبات جديده وقيودا على
التاشيرات بحق من وصفتهم بالاطراف التي
تمارس العنف في البلاد
الى دوامه العقوبات الامريكيه يعود
السودان مجددا بسبب القتال الدائري بين
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع على واقع اعلان
سعودي امريكي يوم الخميس بتعليق محادثات
جده بين طرفي الصراع في السودان نتيجه
انتهاك متكرر لوقف اطلاق النار قصير الامد
وفق السفاره الامريكيه في الخرطوم اعلنت
واشنطن فرض عقوبات جديده وقيود على
التاشيرات بحق من وصفتهم بالاطراف التي
تمارس العنف في السودان بيان وزاره
الخزانه الامريكيه اعلن ادراج اربع شركات
قال انها تدر ايرادات من النزاع في
السودان وتساهم فيه وترتبط بالقوتين
المتقاتلتين وفق وزاره الخزانه الامريكيه
يرتبط بالجيش كيا ناني شملتهما العقوبات
اولهما منظومه الصناعات الدفاعيه وهي شركه
دفاعيه تدر ايرادات بنحو ملياري دولار
وتنتج اسلحه صغيره وتقليديه وذخيره
ومركبات عسكريه للقوات المسلحه السود
الكيان الثاني شركه ماستر تكنولوجي
السودان وهي شركه اسلحه تساهم في عده
شركات تابعه لمنظومه الصناعه الدفاعيه اما
الكيانات التابعان لقوات الدعم السريع
والمشمولان بعقوبات الخزانه الامريكيه
فاول هما شركه الجنيد للانشطه المتعدده
المحدوده وهي شركه قابضه يسيطر عليها
احمدتي وشقيقه وهي تشغل احدى عشره شركه
تابعه عبر قطاعات اقتصاديه عده منها صناعه
مناجم الذهب الكيان الثاني شركه ترادف
لتجاره العامه المحدوده وهي شركه يسيطر
عليها الرائد في الدعم السريع الجوني
حمدان دقلو ومقرها الرئيسي في الامارات
هذه العقوبات وفق الاداره الامريكيه قد
تتبعها اخرى ضد طرفي الصراع في السودان
اذا استمر العنف اللافت ان طرفي الصراع
اتفقا في بيانات منفصله على التقليل من
اثر العقوبات وجدواها وان بصيغ مختلفه
فالجيش تحدث عن دور التصنيع المحلي للعتاد
مشيرا الى ما اعتبره تعليقا فجائيا
لمحادثات جدا اما المستشار السياسي لقوات
الدعم السريع فقال للجزيره ان العقوبات
غير مجديه وجربت مع نظام البشير دون تاثير
لكن سنوات العقوبات الطويله التي صبت على
نظام البشير بما فيها ادراج السودان على
قائمه الارهاب ضغطت كثيرا على اقتصاد
البلاد بدليل مطالبات متواصله برفعها حتى
اكتمل ذلك قبل سنوات قريبه يضع الصراع
الجديد السودان مجددا تحت وطاه عقوبات قد
تتدحرج ككره ثلج وفق الوعيد الامريكي ان
طال امد القتال ما يعني وطئه معاناه ثقيله
تضاف الى كاهل المواطن السوداني
قرر مجلس الامن الدولي تمديد تفويض بعثه
الامم المتحده في السودان لمده سته اشهر
وقد اعرب مجلس الامن عن ادانته الشديده
لجميع الهجمات على السكان المدنيين وموظفي
الامم المتحده والافراد المرتبطين بها
والعاملين في المجال الانساني في السودان
اضافه الى الهجمات التي تستهدف المرافق
الطبيه والعاملين في القطاع الصحي ونهبل
الامدادات الانسانيه ودعم مجلس الامن كذلك
في بيان له جميع الاطراف الى ضمان وصول
المساعدات الانسانيه بسرعه وامان ودون
عوائق في جميع انحاء السودان
[موسيقى]
عود الان الى موضوع التوترات في البلقان
لنسلط الضوء على اقليم كوسوفو من حيث
النشاه والظروف التي رافقت ظهوره ككيانا
سياسي يقع هذا الاقليم في منطقه البلقان
جنوب شرقي اوروبا تحده جمهوريه مقدونيا من
الجنوب الشرقي صربيا من الشمال الشرقي
الجبل الاسود من الشمال الغربي والبانيا
من الجنوب عام
1999 اندلعت حرب كسه بين جيش تحرير كوسوفا
الالباني ومعه حلف النيتو وبين الحكومه
اليوغزلفيه والقوات الصربيه بدا القتال في
فبراير شباط 98 واستمر حتى يوليو تموز 99
غادر معظم الصرب من كتبه بعد الحرب ونشرت
نشرت قواته حفظ سلاما امميه في المنطقه
وخضعت
اداره الامم المتحده في يونيو حزيران تسعه
وتسعين وقعت يوغسلافيا والنيتو معاهده
سلام سميت كومانوفو وقد نصت على استبدال
القوات الصربيه بقوات دوليه دوليه فانسحبت
هذه القوات واعيدا مليون الباني وخمسمائه
الف ناسح وفي عام 2008 اعلنت كسب
والاستقلال من جانب واحد تعترف تسعه
وتسعون دوله من اصل 1993 دوله منضمه تحت
لواء الامم المتحده تعترف باستقلال [__] امه
بما في ذلك الولايات المتحده والمملكه
المتحده واثنتان وعشرون دوله من اصل 27
دوله في الاتحاد الاوروبي لكن روسيا
والصين اللتين لا تعترفان باستقلال كوسوفو
منعت عضويه كوسوفو في الامم المتحده
تعد جمهوريه كوسوفو وعاصمتها برشتينا اصغر
دوله في البلقان بمساحه نحو 11 الف كيلو
متر مربع وعدد سكان يقارب المليونين سنه
الاحداث الراهنه في كوسوفو هي نتاج
تراكمات تاريخيا بين الصرب والالبان
ولطالما عصفت بالاقليم جولات توتر كثيره
ففي ديسمبر الماضي اندلعت اشتباكات بين
الشرطه والاقليه الصربيه بعد ان اعلنت
حكومه كوسوفو اجراء انتخابات محليه في
بلديات ذات اغلبيه صربيه في مايو ايار عام
2019 تسببت عمليه عسكريه اطلقتها شرطه
كوسوفو ضد شبكات تهريب في مناطق ذات
اغلبيه صربيه تسببت في صدمات داميه حين
حاول السكان التصدي لها كما اندلعت
اشتباكات في يوليو تموز من عام 2011 بين
سلطات كوسوفو والصرب في شمال الاقليم
الذين قطعوا حركه السير بالشاحنات عندما
حاولت الشرطه السيطره على معابر حدوديه مع
صربيا
تنضموا الينا الان من لندن السيده دونيكا
ايميني الباحثه المختصه في شؤون البلقان
اهلا وسهلا بك سيدتي هل الامور قابله
للتفجر اكثر في اقليم كوسوفو
شكرا جزيلا لاستضافه
يسعدني اكون جزء من برنامجكم
[موسيقى]
هناك توترات في كوسوفو وهذا هو وضع قائم
منذ اعلان استقباله كوزفو وايضا بعد
الانتهاء الحرب في بدايه الفين
لكن خلال الاسبوع الماضي حصل وما زلنا نرى
اشياء اشياء وهي ازمه ادت حتى الى تدخل
قوات النيتو على الارض وهذا امر لم يحصل
منذ نشر هذه القوات في كوسوفو طبعا نحن
قلقون جدا حول الوضع وان قوه الناتو
والاتحاد الاوروبي والولايات المتحده
تدخلوا مباشره وفورا فلم ظن اجتماع الامس
نجد ان رئيس الصربيا سيد كوتشيتش
والرئيسه كوسوفو عثماني والتقوا بالرئيس
المقرون الفرنسي
والاستشار
وما حصل بالامس سبق اجتماع قصير
تمثلت تقدم سهل الاتحاد الاوروبي ثلاث
نقاط على الاتفاق موافق عليها لتخفيف
التصعيد على الارض في كوسوفو حاليا كوسوفو
الان تدرس هذه النقاط الثلاثه وهي وهي
تتعلق بمساله البلديات الموجوده في شمال
كوزوف هذه المحاوله ليست لحل موضوع
المشاكل بينفو والصربيا بل اي فقط لتخفيف
التصعيد الموقف على امل عدم حصول حرب اخرى
في اوروبا فكما تعلمون جيدا نموذ العدوان
الروسي على اوكرانيا قبل سنتين نحن نعاني
من هذا المشاكل في البرقان
نحن والغرب كل الناس في حاله تاهب وخطر
هذا الخطر هل هو ايضا ناتج على ادنى تفكك
السابقه الى صربيا وكرواتيا والبوسنه
والهرسك وغير ذلك لم يتم على اسس سليمه
وبالتالي اسباب الانفجار ما زالت ق ائمه
يمكن عمليه سهله وكان تفكك عنيف جدا
وشهوات داله حروف كثيره بدا
الحرفيا واخيرا حرب كوسوفو حيث احتاج
التدخل النيتو في نهايه التسعينيات
والتدخل في كوسوفو حصل بعد ان قام
الغربي مشاهده بنظام المناسبه الذي قام
بتطهير عرقي في جدول اعماله وما حصل لاحقا
هو الكثير من مشاكل السياسيه نتجت عن
الحرب الروسلافيه فالدنيا عن سته دول
فيما كان يسمى
سابقا سوفينيو اوكرانيا التي فعلت جزء من
الاتحاد الاوروبي ونخسر جبل الاسود
وايضا
وبالتالي كل هذه الدول لديها مشاكل ثنائيه
وليس فقط مشاكل بين وصربيا هذه اكثر بروزه
وهي نتحدث عنها اليوم والتي تبقينا دائما
مشغولين
الخوف من التوترات والحروب ولكن هل هناك
ايضا لدينا وضع غير مستقل في البوس
وايضا لدينا حاله عدم استقرار في الجبل
الاسود
وكرواتيا ايضا مع الاسف ليسوا جيران دون
مشاكل
وبالتالي فان كوسوفو نعم هي واحده من
المشاكل التي حاليا موضع تحت الاعين ولكن
عندما انهارت وتجزات
سهل وما زلنا نعاني نتائج سياسيه وامنيه
حصل قبل الثالثين سنه فلو نظرنا الوضع في
كوزو حاليا فهو يشبه حد كبير ما شاهدناه
في التسعينات مع الاسف عندما قامت اضطرت
الولايات المتحده الترك العالم
والتدخل في كوسوفو
اليوم نشاهد شكرا شكرا جزيلا لك السيده
دونيكا عفوا على هذه المقاطعه شكرا لك
بهذا نصل الى نهايه الحصاد موعدكم يتجدد
عند راس الساعه مع نشره منتصف الليل في
امان الله
[موسيقى]